a homosexual poet a drunken artist a man
who has a relationship with the
volleyball a sexual deviant a guy who
likes to wear gladiator outfits but
enough about me
here to present the Award for Best Actor
is last year's winner of the award for
best actress Hilary Swank
[Music]
thank you last year much was made about
someone that I forgot to thank but Chad
knows how grateful I am for him so I
would like to take this quick moment to
think someone else I forgot dad thank
you for all your support tonight's
nominees for Best Performance by an
actor in a leading role are Javier
Bardem in before nightfall
[Applause]
ed Harris in Pollock Geoffrey Rush in
quills
and the Oscar goes to Russell Crowe
[Applause]
this is the first Oscar and the second
nomination for Russell Crowe he was
nominated in this category last year for
the insider
[Music]
[Applause]
my grandfather's name was Stan Weems it
was a cinematographer in the Second
World War
my uncle David David William Crowe he
died last year the age of 66 I'd like to
thank the Academy for something here
which is pretty surprising and dedicated
to two men who still continue to inspire
me I also like to thank my mum and dad
who I just don't thank enough I suppose
and an incredible cast Joaquin Phoenix
Connie Nielsen jamun han-soo Ralph more
expensive trick Park magnificent Richard
Harris the late Oliver Reed Tamar
Serrano Tommy Flanagan Derek Jacobi and
everybody else
DreamWorks a great company and a vital
and a journalized contributor to the art
form - Doug wick David Franz Oney Bruno
Lustig and Terry Needham and a very
brave crew collected from 22 different
countries around the world
- the people that work for me here work
with me my personal Cavalry George
Freeman Allen her got Larry wit sir
Shirley Pierce Robin bomb mark done
Braille but really folks you know I owe
this to one bloke and his name is really
Scott
you know when you when you grow up in
the suburbs of Sydney or Auckland or
Newcastle like Ridley or Jamie Bell or
the suburbs of anywhere you know a dream
like this seems kind of vaguely
ludicrous and completely unattainable
but this moment is directly connected to
those childhood imaginings and for
anybody who's on the downside of
advantage and relying purely on courage
it's possible thanks very much
[Music]